I'm going to talk to you today about, I decided to start more broad because I realized that
the audience is between lymphoma, myeloma, and leukemia.
So I'm going to talk to you about why we're excited about the combination of BCL-2 and
menin inhibition, and then I'll take you through some of the zyftominib data.
So first, the mechanism of action of menin inhibitors.
So menin inhibitors are the latest targeted therapies approved for acute myeloid leukemia.
They are approved for these indications, KMT-2A rearranged leukemias, which used to be called
MLL, mixed lineage leukemia, which happened in about 5% to 10% of acute leukemia, and
MPM-1 mutant acute leukemia, 25% to 30% of AML.
The common thing about both of these genotypes is upregulation of HOX genes, which are normally
stem cell programmed, so they're hijacked because of this HOX upregulation that leads
to differentiation and arrest, and menin inhibitors create a wedge between menin and KMT-2A,
these two proteins, that causes downregulation of HOX genes and an anti-leukemic effect.
So there are two menin inhibitors approved, revuminib and zyftominib.
There are multiple menin inhibitors right now in clinical investigation, and these are
the structures of these menin inhibitors.
So you can think of them as medicines similar to revuminib or medicines similar to zyftominib.
The circled part is the part that binds to the menin pocket.
And there are now even second-generation menin inhibitors entering the clinic, with AstraZeneca's
trial launched and the CHARM study about to launch.
And this is because there's robust data showing that these menin inhibitors work.
So revuminib is approved for both KMT-2A and MPM-1 for relapsed refractory acute leukemia
age 1 and above, and zyftominib is approved for NPM-1 relapsed and refractory acute myeloid
leukemia.
And the reason why we got approval is because these medicines improved on the historical
outcomes in these genotypes.
So if you look at KMT-2A rearranged leukemias, especially if they've had two or more lines
of therapy, their median overall survival is less than a few months.
Whereas for NPM-1, for first salvage, the outcomes are reasonable.
They're not favorable, but they're just like any other relapsed refractory leukemia.
And then for MPM-1, they're just like any other relapsed refractory leukemia.
And then for later salvage lines, it is worse.
So MENIN inhibitors lead to a CR-CRH rate of roughly 20% to 30%, but the duration of response
in this and relapsed refractory disease is limited to about six months.
And that's mostly because of these mutations.
The best described mechanism of resistance is these MEN1 mutations.
These are binding site mutation of these inhibitors that disrupt the binding of MENIN.
And in this case, or sorry, disrupt the binding of the drug.
Do not disrupt the binding.
And there could be a specific set of mutations for each of these MEN1 inhibitors that would affect
the choice of MEN1 inhibitors in the future.
So just like CML, you may imagine one day a heat map where you have a mutation,
and you're going to say, this one works better for zoftominib versus revumenib, et cetera.
So aside from being practical of combining BCL2 inhibition and MEN1 inhibition,
because Benetoclax is a standard of care,
there's excellent science that says that if you have a MEN1 inhibitor,
there's good science to support this combination.
The basis for it is from these early studies showing that a BCL2 inhibitor targets more the stem-like cells in leukemia,
whereas a MEN1 inhibitor would target more the common myeloprogenitor-like phenotype.
And then the combination would eradicate leukemia, both, you know, progenitor and stem cells.
And that would lead to prolonged survival in these animal models.
In addition, there's more recent studies showing that MEN1 inhibition,
in fact, down-regulates BCL2 expression and MCL1 expression.
So that could induce sensitivity to BCL2 inhibition.
So that's the basis of multiple clinical trials that have shown these results.
Our IST at MD Anderson is safe, but there are also investigator,
there are also company-sponsored studies, such as the ACE of N-zoftominib.
There's Frontline, there's Rehabs Refractory.
I will just use the first two studies to pinpoint the importance of MEN1 and BCL2,
and I'll give you a little bit more detail on that as we go along.
And I'll give you a little bit more detail on that as we go along.
So, for example, FA-revuminib led to far less response compared to the studies with BCL2 and MEN1.
And that is probably because all these patients were exposed to cytarabine,
and the magnitude of the effect seen with FA-revuminib is mostly the revuminib,
and less the chemotherapy, whereas BCL2 and MEN1 inhibition seems to be synergistic.
So, the COMET-007 is a large study that investigated either 7+3+-zoftominib as a phase 1,
or 8-7+-zoftominib as a phase 1.
There was a relapsed refractory population, and then a newly diagnosed population.
And we presented these data at ASH about the relapsed refractory population.
So, it included NPM1 mutant patients, 51 patients, and KMT2A rearranged patients.
And the bulk of the study in here that we're going to present is focused
on the NPM1 mutant population.
So, the recommended phase 2 dose of zoftominib is 600 milligrams daily.
And these are patients that were heavily pretreated, about 51% had prior venetoclax,
about 20% had prior transplant.
And what we saw is, you know, side effects that are things we expect
with an HMA/VEN combination relapsed refractory setting without excessive toxicity.
So, there was no clear increase in myelosuppression with zoftominib.
There was acceptable count recovery.
There is -- there wasn't a high --
a rate of QT prolongation.
And like what we saw with other targeted agents, there was lower rate
of differentiation syndrome, which is the main class effect of these drugs.
So, when used in combination, there's less expected differentiation syndrome.
So, the overall response rate with HMA/VEN and zoftominib was 65%.
The CR rate was 27% with an excellent MRD negativity rate.
And this was done by flow, but also we did some analysis
by in vivo scribe showing high rates of MRD negativity.
Impressively, the overall survival in this relapsed refractory cohort was great.
For someone -- for an NPM1 refractory cohort, a median duration of CRC was 39 weeks.
So, this is excellent, especially for those who are VEN naive.
There's less of a benefit, probably, for those that are VEN exposed.
So, in conclusion, I hope that I showed you preclinical studies showing strong support
or synergy between BCL2 and menin inhibition across --
multiple trials, the combination of the menin inhibitor zoftominib at the RP2D,
which is 600 milligrams with VEN and EZA, is well-tolerated and is showing deep
and durable remissions in patients with relapsed refractory NPM1 mutant acute myeloid leukemia.
And there are -- based on these results, based on the results
of multiple trials incorporating menin inhibitors,
there are multiple pivotal randomized studies launched testing the addition of menin inhibition
to either EZA or VEN.
And I'm going to talk to you in another session about design of these trials.
Thank you.